[Music]
happy Halloween everybody in honor of
this spooky costume holiday we have set
out to determine what is the greatest
horror movie franchise of all time we
have a certain set of criteria that
determines what films are eligible for
this competition there must be at least
three films in the franchise and they
must include either ghosts demons
zombies serial killers or the
supernatural and we've ranked them
according to total box-office gross
adjusted for inflation and we have an
awesome panel of horror heads and movie
fanatics to help us with this grand
endeavor first Oh an old friend of the
show he's the founder of I mockery comm
and he's the creator of a Bobo's big
adventure welcome back to the show Roger
bar good to see you how Oh whoo and this
gentleman uh he's an actor a bon vivant
a Renaissance man you've seen him in
compliance cheap thrills Captain America
and he's recently uh gone into
post-production on his feature
directorial debut very impressive
welcome back to the show Pat Healy thank
you thank you how and it's his first
time on the show but it's not his first
time in the hallways of screen junkies
he's all over sj+ and he writes and
researches movie fights
welcome to the show Juan Harris hey
thanks for having me now gentlemen there
are 16 films ranked 1 to 16 we have them
matched up and seated
1 verse 16 to verse 15 etc are you ready
to go down into the basement and figure
this out
let's do it all right the first matchup
our number one seed The Exorcist versus
the number 16 seed Hellraiser
Roger Barr I gotta go with Hellraiser on
this one actually because we're talking
about franchise versus a single film Wow
okay you just pick the 16 seat over the
1 seed did we just buy a ticket to upset
City
I think there's nine Hellraiser movies
if I'm correct they're on Netflix I
hadn't seen
any of them since the first one when it
came out in the 80s and I saw them all
last year and none of them are good The
Exorcist is ik I'm sorry anyone involved
I mean I like the first one I should say
exorcist too is a great bizarre weird
movie I like that thumb and I also like
Exorcist 3 quite a bit too they don't
come anywhere near close to being as
good as The Exorcist was one of the
greatest movies ever made but I would
have to go with the Exorcist boom we are
locked up at 1-1 lon Harris you are the
deciding vote yeah I think I got to
break the time this one with Hellraiser
I love the original Exorcist I agree
it's maybe the greatest horror movie
ever but man Exorcist - The Heretic just
kills the average of that whole
franchise it's just so such a slog and
again your choice is Hellraiser I'm
going hello in a stunning upset
Hellraiser moving on to the second round
the number 9 seed poltergeist against
the number 8 seed paranormal activity as
weak as the sequels are in a lot of
cases I think you got to go poltergeist
on this one just for that original film
poltergeist was so trailblazing that
movie is so memorable to me that blows
away the entire Paranormal Activity
franchise BAM 100 poltergeist let's come
around - Roger bar oh yeah I'm all about
poltergeist I'm a huge fan of the
original three films Pat your boat is
moot because they both voted from anyway
no you cannot yes you can
poltergeist is my favorite horror movie
of all time oh wow
so it's poltergeist in a clean sweep you
guys didn't really say anything nice
about paranormal activity so I will
right now they were very cheap to make
those films okay our next first-round
matchup Halloween versus the Living Dead
films I'd like to start with Pat Healy
that's a tough one yeah man the original
Halloween is a classic you know the
second one is good - the third one I
love it's a cult classic it's finally
people are recognizing it I don't like
any of them I don't think after that I
think just there's more movies that are
better in the Living Dead category so
I'd have to go with the Living Dead so
it's one Oh Living Dead
Roger bar I got to go Halloween the
reason being is I've just watched them
more over the years they're my you know
Halloween season popcorn like I come
back and watch the marathons of
them on AMC every year and all I think
overall I've definitely watched
Halloween a lot more gotcha all tied up
Halloween versus the Living Dead films
lawn Harris wow this one is really
really tough but to me like the Living
Dead Romero films are that's that's the
backbone that's the blueprint of modern
horror I think I got to go
living-dead Romero unbelievable huge
upset the number 13 seed the Living Dead
knocking off Halloween let's talk about
our number five seed the scream
franchise versus the number 12 seed
child's play I guess I'd give the
advantage to scream because people did
go absolutely bonkers over it Chucky I
mean you know he's a lot of fun it's a
funny movie I've always wanted to see
Chucky verse leprechaun I can't believe
Freddy vs. Jason happened but that one
didn't one Oh scream thank you sir Pat
Healy I'm going to profess my ignorance
a little bit here I think I've only seen
the first two screen movies which I like
and the theme several the child's play
movies on it and some of those Chucky
movies are unwatchable so I would have
to say scream as well BAM
there you go scream moving on sorry
Chucky you sucky alright let's move on
to the other side of the bracket we're
still in the first round
Friday the 13th our number two seed
versus our number 15 seed the Evil Dead
I think this one may be the easiest
definitely that we've had so far because
it's Evil Dead all day for me I mean
Friday the 13th most of those movies are
not memorable whereas Evil Dead every
single evil them with it there's only
been four but they're all great and
three of them are classic Sam one oh the
Evil Dead let's come around to Roger um
yeah I mean I love absolutely love both
series like Friday 13th
it's the perfect movie marathon
franchise I think it really is one one
we go to Pat Healy to break this tie I
gotta add good with Lana I think there
are some fun things in those Friday the
13th movies but I don't think I would
call any of them a good movie I mean I
enjoyed that third one maybe the the
most Evil Dead 2 is the life changing
movie for me when I saw that that I
never saw anything the same again this
may have you out there sharpening your
machetes but the number 15 seed Evil
Dead has knocked off the number 2 seed
for
the 13th the number 10 seed Texas
Chainsaw Massacre versus the number 7
seed the Saw franchise I would have to
say Texas Chainsaw Massacre for this
well the fourth film I'm not crazy about
it they've done some good reboots of the
series that were a lot of fun and the
original one it's another absolute
classic one Oh Texas Chainsaw Pat Healy
yeah I would have to agree I think toeb
uber is absolutely one of the masters of
horn just the first movie alone it
stands alone as a classic so I'd have to
go with Texas Chainsaw Master it's - Oh
Texas Chainsaw Massacre moves on can we
say that no one saw that coming I think
we just did all right another barn
burner the number three seed Nightmare
on Elm Street versus the number 14 seed
insidious poor insidious it maybe if
insidious was up against saw it would
have had a chance but in this one no
chance you got to go with nightmare and
Freddy Krueger one of the if not the
most iconic villain in modern all one
two Freddy's coming for insidious Roger
bar I am ready for Freddy hell BAM
that's it Nightmare on Elm Street moving
on here's the final matchup of the first
round featuring the number 11 seed final
destination versus the number six seed
psycho I am a huge fan of the final
destination movies those I seen multiple
times as hard as it is the same insight
goes one of my favorite films of all
time but has its franchise I'd have to
say final destination final destination
100 over succeed psycho lon
I think I got to go psycho on this I I
really think psycho two is a very
stretch weird but it is a really strong
movie considering it came twenty two
years later and it's like 80s and it's
in color it should be atrociously
horrible and it's not actually takes a
really interesting twist on norman three
is like an for the TV movie I haven't
really seen recently but I think just on
the strength of those first two got to
go psycho we are locked up at 1 1 Roger
bar
you didn't need sequels to psycho you
don't need any of those sequels at all
it's fine as a standalone film and we're
talking about franchises here the final
destination films they're just so much
fun so finalists that's such a great
point about psycho being such a
standalone film versus this franchise
that really some
up for me and final destination
destination second round all right round
two our number 16 seed a Cinderella
hellraiser versus the number nine seed
poltergeist Pat Healy poltergeist boom
lon Harris let's keep the competitive I
think I'm going Hellraiser on this one I
think I go Hellraiser
Roger barb decides the fate of these two
films the Hellraiser series I've
definitely watched them more but it
introduced this fun new villain that was
unlike anything else the first three
films I just there's some of my
favorites
Hellraiser will be raising hell in the
next round
our next Elite Eight matchup the Living
Dead films versus the scream franchise I
don't know how you don't go with Romero
and the Living Dead I mean Night of the
Living Dead a foundational movie Dawn of
the Dead with a great sort of satires a
tall par like those are the superior
movies The Scream is fun and it was
great like a new twist on slasher movies
but I don't think they're on the same
level really BAM one Oh Living Dead
let's go to Roger I'm in agreement yeah
Living Dead they're just there's on such
a higher level Living Dead living to see
the next round let's go to the other
side of the bracket the Evil Dead vs
Texas Chainsaw Massacre I would have to
go with the Evil Dead I think there's at
three really great solid movies and I
think the first Texas Chainsaw Massacre
is a classic and the second is fun and
then after that it's a little
wishy-washy where's those first three
Evil Dead especially the second one I
mean just that one alone is one of the
greatest so I have to say IVA bed boom
Evil Dead 1 Oh Roger bar I agree about
Evil Dead if we're looking at it as a
franchise I think Texas Chainsaw had
some of the worst sequels compared to
Evil Dead that's 204 the Evil Dead it is
moving on this next one Nightmare on Elm
Street versus final destination I think
I got to go final destination because
there's a lot of those I know there's a
lot of the Freddy movies that I don't
really like where I don't think there's
a really bum final destination movie
there isn't one that pulls down the
overall average so I think I got to go
with that even though it kills me
because I loved those original Freddy
move final destination 1 Oh Roger you
look like him like he grew wing
was one yeah definitely in the heart I
just invaded your dream flesh so Roger
talk to I'm a total Fred head Freddy is
Freddy is my all-time favorite horror
movie killer
there's no one like him he has the most
iconic horror movie weapon ever with the
Blade II glove so it's 1 1 Street
absolutely Elm Street read without a
doubt boom Nightmare on Elm Street one
final destination 1 Pat Healy decides
this battle Nightmare on Elm Street
verse final destination the character of
Freddy Krueger there isn't a character
that's that iconic in that grade and
that evolving in the final destination
movie so that's a really tough choice
but it comes down to being the character
Freddy Krueger so I would have to say
the Elm Street movies boom there you go
Nightmare on Elm Street oh how much I
love the final destination movies 3 for
better open the door to the next round
for Nightmare on Elm Street our final
four is set the number 16 seed
Hellraiser against the number 13 seed
living dead at Healey
well I'm no secret that I'm no great fan
of the Hellraiser movies there's no
comparison between that series and the
Living Dead series I mean those movies
are classics alright Living Dead 1 Oh
Living Dead
Roger bar I have to agree the Living
Dead ones I think that series is far
greater when you look at it as a whole
yeah
Living Dead moving on lon you agree I'm
100% against sweet Living Dead going to
the finals
our next Final Four matchup number 15
seed the Evil Dead versus the number
three seed Nightmare on Elm Street Roger
was just hurts this hurts it's trying to
choose between your two favorite kids or
something like oh man
I wish it was that easy I have to go
with Freddy the Elm Street series
introduced something completely
different it's killing people in their
dreams there's just nothing like it out
there and that's why they've held up so
well over the years as much as I love
Evil Dead I got to go Elm Street 1 Oh
will it be sweet dreams for nightmare
we'll find out lawn Harris it's
interesting because these are both like
series it started really serious and
then became joke e'er and funnier over
time so it's interesting to compare them
but I think I still have to go evil
and if only because when it became jokey
er its funnier and to have it still be
so successful and still maintain that
same quality so yeah I think I got to go
evil bed sam raimi we are all locked up
at one one and this might be the most
exciting moment on the Internet where
Pat Healy like rakes
thy evil dead Nightmare on Elm Street
sir it's tough if I were to say if I
liked Evil Dead 2 or the nightmare hour
Nightmare on Elm Street better I would
have to say Evil Dead 2 but as a
franchise I have to go with Freddy
ladies and gentlemen the finals are set
we're about to determine the greatest
horror franchise of all time and we have
number 3 Nightmare on Elm Street versus
number 13 the Living Dead franchise
we've left a wake of blood bodies
chainsaws machetes behind us but it was
all for this moment right here
nightmare versus Living Dead Pat Healy
tough one
Night of the Living Dead and Dawn of the
Dead and those other very very good
movies including the remake are superb
movies of any genre so as much as I love
Freddy and I love Nightmare on Elm
Street movies I do like all of them with
the exception of the remake I got to go
with the Living Dead 1 Oh Living Dead
films Roger bar Elm Street films are
just so important to me it's one of the
earliest horror movies I ever saw Freddy
Krueger himself it's such an easy
character look like there are so many
moments in those series that I just look
back on and laugh and love and they mean
so much whereas the dead series they're
excellent I love them but there's no
like central character that everyone
really remembers though I got to go Elm
Street Wow
we are all locked up at 1:1 determining
the greatest horror movie franchise of
all time lon Harris talk to us well I
I've been down on Freddy this whole time
it sounds like I really hate that
franchise and I don't but I'm afraid
Freddy's dead because I got a pic of the
Living Dead movies giving it to George
Romero we have crowned our champion
douse them in blood like carry on prom
night it is George Romero's Living Dead
the master of zombie har has taken it
guys what an emotional journey it was
what did you think about their choices
what in your s
is the greatest horror franchise of all
time and also what are you gonna be for
Halloween let us know in the comments
section below we want to know I want to
thank this awesome panel you guys really
brought it today
Roger bar thank you sir expose Pat Healy
thanks for being here and lawn Harris
thank you for coming across the hall and
being on the screen oh great having you
man and thank you for watching I'm Hal
Rudnick hit me up on Twitter happy
Halloween bye bye Suda for a
heartwarming holiday classic full of
incredible animation amazing songs and
haunting visuals that makes every emo
kid feel special and unique even though
they're all in love with the same movie
Oh